[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
what's your guess
of who the first member of Congress to
be subpoenaed by Jack Smith
or maybe the target
I don't know Scott Perry he said his
phone seized hasn't he
was he on the list of text messages holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know they they yell and
scream about Hunter Biden's lamp to him
Well everybody's laptop 100 left that
top this laptop that
how about a [ __ ] cell phone I don't
know the former Chief of Staff Mark
Meadows how about we do how about we do
a real investigation on the cell phone
my friend Rachel bittickoffer this
morning tweeted that if there is a
republican investigation in the house or
anywhere we need to call it a sham
investigation and I am all for that
messaging get that in your brain put
that down into sham investigation just
like the coup attempt was the Cheeto
dust kangaroo coup Donald Trump is the
Cheeto dust q and honor
Mark Meadows is apparently the the coup
texter
the coup Communicator apparently holy
[ __ ] there's 30 there's a 34.
the 34 members of Congress
that was texting this guy's on ideas you
know just snowballing the coup
trying to figure out ways to coo and
stuff
what in the actual [ __ ]
and then Marjorie Taylor green I don't
know if you got this in some of these
text messages Marjorie Taylor green
which we've talked about
um she said if I was gonna plan if I was
gonna plan the coup we would have won
because we would have brought guns and
we would have committed violence
she literally said that [ __ ]
I'm not making that [ __ ] [ __ ] up she
said if we plan if we meaning her and
Steve Bannon planned the coup on January
6th
that they would have won
because they would have brought guns and
[ __ ]
maybe they'd have brought a pipe bomb I
don't know I'm just saying [ __ ]
saying they haven't found the pipe bomb
yet the pipe bomber yet
maybe just maybe
maybe I don't know she's saying if she
planned it she'd bring arms hmm
makes sense to me maybe to you but 34
[ __ ] members of Congress including
Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan
they were desperate desperate
thank you
to make Donald Trump the dictator the
king
the Republican Jesus they were desperate
as they are desperate
any day of the week
what do you think the projection is
especially out of the Twitter q and
honor
Elon Musk Jesus Christ this guy [ __ ] I
don't know what he's reading or who's in
his ear but God damn
God damn
really Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan tweeting from the uh GOP
Judiciary house account
Elon
Trump Kanye really honestly he's not far
off these [ __ ] these [ __ ] three
guys are off their goddamn rocker I mean
they love him don't get me wrong that's
why they deleted the [ __ ]
because they they want they want Elon
Trump and Kanye to be the party and the
message leaders that's what they want
it's what Jim Jordan wants
got a hard on for that
but apparently Jim Jordan was trying to
come up with coup ideas too
yeah just snowballing a bit
oh [ __ ] now a lot of people are making
bones about the way they spell martial
law and Marshall is not spelled wrong
it's just the wrong Marshall right
it's not you know they thought they were
going to go to the store Marshals I
guess maybe who knows but see you know
we can mock them for that and you can
talk about that [ __ ] where they're
misspelling and how dumb they are but
really honestly that is not that is not
what we need to be talking about here
well we need to be talking about is
there are 34 [ __ ] members of One
party
that were in the House of
Representatives that were trying their
damnedest to overthrow our vote
I don't know I don't know how else to
say it there were 34 members elected
officials of Congress
actively trying to figure out a way to
overthrow our vote
they're [ __ ] fascist I don't they're
Nazis what what I've been yelling and
screaming it for for [ __ ] two years
I don't know how more much evidence we
need for this to [ __ ] finally sink in
that that the Republican party has
become the America First Nazi party
they were going to overthrow our
constitution folks
just like the geodesk Q anoner said A
week ago or whenever and he's probably
still saying it I'm gonna terminate the
Constitution
and make me the rightful winner because
he's terrified he's going to be indicted
and Mark Meadows holy [ __ ] if he hasn't
flipped Mark Marky Mark you better
[ __ ] start flipping buddy holy [ __ ]
you are gonna serve some serious prison
time you dumb [ __ ] whoosh
holy [ __ ]
and I don't know if you're the FBI
informant I have no idea I have no clue
and really honestly some of these text
messages from these members of Congress
I mean yeah you want to say they're
criminal but at the same time they're
just [ __ ] boneheads they're just
[ __ ] stupid
they're so they're so entrenched in
their goddamn privilege and they're so
ins entrenched in their elitism
that they couldn't even see the light of
day then it's not it's not about your
one [ __ ] president this one
point in time you [ __ ] dummy
in 2016 Donald Trump won on a
technicality he did not win the popular
vote he was not going to be ever a
popular president
it wasn't gonna happen
but he won
in the Electoral College was certified
and they voted Jesus Christ Joe Biden
presided over the joint session to
certify that [ __ ] vote you dumb
[ __ ]
what do you think democracy is
other than the peaceful transfer of
power when you let that go
when you absolutely ignore
that we must have a peaceful transfer of
power you lose all legitimacy of your
democracy especially this one
it's so important
in this time that we realize that the
misspelling of Marshall is not the most
important factor here yes it's easy to
mock
but there were 34 members of the
Republican caucus
that we're trying to undo the
Constitution that grants them their
[ __ ] power
to vote for their constituency and
represent their District
and they had no [ __ ] clue no they
didn't even [ __ ] blink
didn't even question rather they should
be trying to overthrow the election
on January 6. not no not even knowing
that it's all ceremonial
The Joint session the certify the
Electoral College it's it's [ __ ]
ceremonial you stupid bastards the
states decide the States you want to
talk about states rights you states
rights dumb sons of [ __ ]
it's the state's rights to certify that
vote and when the state certify that
vote that's it I can't believe we are we
are almost two years two years into
January six and I have to sit here in
front of a microphone and explain to
dumb [ __ ] how it's supposed to
work when they watched what happened
so I don't know if Mark Meadows has
flipped yet but oh my God
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
he better start
that yesterday Jack Smith speaking of
the January 6.
Insurrection and the Cheeto dust
kangaroo coup attempt Jack Smith
subpoenas Brad rattlersberger I don't
know if you remember this name or not
but Brad rathersberger is a secretary of
state in Georgia
now this is really important and the
reason why it's really important is
because the weekend before the January
6th Insurrection Donald Trump called and
threatened and begged and pleaded for
Brad rattlersberger to find 11 000 so
many [ __ ] votes so he could win
because he just needed one state to so
doubt that's all he needed Arizona
Georgia Michigan Pennsylvania he didn't
give a [ __ ] which one it was they wanted
they wanted Mike Pence to stand on the
floor of the joint session and say well
we can't certify Georgia so we can't
certify any of it that's what they
[ __ ] wanted that's his State elector
scheme and really with Jack Smith's
appeaning Brad Roethlisberger this
pretty much
um destroys Fannie Willis's case in
Georgia State case it's now a federal
case I don't know if you if you're
paying attention or not
but the whole [ __ ] Georgia case
that Fannie Willis has
the linchpin is that [ __ ] phone call
and the pressure that Trump and his
allies put on the Secretary of State to
to just
find votes just find them under a
mattress [ __ ] under your desk wherever
don't give a [ __ ] he wanted to win
at least he wanted to say that
serious [ __ ] business here folks this
is not this is not [ __ ] that we can just
[ __ ] glaze over
34 [ __ ] members of Congress wanted to
[ __ ] on our constitution
the one they sworn out to
now I don't know if it's criminal but it
sure as hell deserves a [ __ ] ethics
investigation which they're not gonna do
now that they gerrymandered certain
States and it caused a just a slim
majority
for them to have a speaker who God knows
who the [ __ ] they're gonna make speaker
they don't [ __ ] know it ain't going
to be Kevin McCarthy I the longer this
goes on the more I think well he ain't
going to be able to pull 218 no [ __ ]
way
no [ __ ] way
and really honestly at this point
just to make a complete [ __ ] mockery
out of them democrats should get
together and vote unanimously for Liz
Cheney I'm not [ __ ] you I'm not a
Liz Cheney fan you know that [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
but by God by God at least at least we
wouldn't have [ __ ] sham investigation
after sham investigation to [ __ ]
distract us
from the real [ __ ] crimes and the
real [ __ ] coup attempt
there was no goddamn 2020 [ __ ] stolen
election you stupid bastards and the
evidence is not on Hunter Biden's laptop
the evidence is on Mark Meadows phone
got it
it's not it's not [ __ ] rocket science
there's dick pics on Hunter Biden's
laptop
there's coup plotting on Mark Meadows
phone
so any investigation by any Republican
that is not that is not trying to figure
out in their party who the [ __ ] they're
going to bounce from Congress is a sham
investigation at this point
oh I know what they're gonna do Hunter
Biden's laptop the 2020 riots black
lives matter oh they're gonna go down
that hole I wouldn't I would not be
surprised that if if
if Kevin McCarthy or some other dumb
[ __ ] becomes the speaker of the
house that they start talking about
Hitler in committee meetings I'm not
[ __ ] you
doubt me [ __ ] you doubt me because that
is exactly their [ __ ] messaging right
now now it's gonna get even worse folks
because Trump is falling in the [ __ ]
polls and if you think that's a good
thing
let me remind you who who [ __ ] owns
and runs the chaos machine in the
Republican party it's Trump
and you don't think he'll get more
desperate as DeSantis Rises as the power
inside the Republican Party
apps of [ __ ] lutely he's going to
he's already a caged animal
now try not feeding that animal
but [ __ ] him
they're gonna do what they're gonna do
Nazis are gonna Nazi folks there ain't a
goddamn thing you can do about it
besides point it out and mock the holy
living [ __ ] out of them
and every single [ __ ] committee and Sham
investigation that they run through in
the house we must mock them at every
[ __ ] turn and we have to pay
attention to what they're doing
because the mark Meadows text messages
of 34 members of the House
of this
oh my God it was it was just it was just
a [ __ ] it was a crowd surfing of coup
ideas it's insanity
we have to keep our eye on the ball and
our our eye needs to be on our democracy
look the Democrats and Joe Biden have a
good handle on their end okay I know I
know a lot of people don't like to hear
the Joe baby blah blah I I don't give a
[ __ ]
Joe Biden and the Democrats have a good
handle on what they're doing
and I believe that this new Congress
even in the minority and the majority in
the Senate have a good handle on what
they're going to do even with [ __ ] like
Cinema being an independent and all that
garbage
don't let the good stuff distract you
from what we need to pay attention to
it's vitally important
that we do not look away
as these [ __ ] try to take away our
democracy again
because they're at it I don't know if
you pay an attention to Twitter and
you're like oh what does Twitter have to
do with our you don't think that Elon
Musk is running cover for the
Republicans every big story the last two
weeks there's another Twitter files drop
oh Hunter button dick pics
foreign
[ __ ] from Elon Musk
he's running cover for them
that's all it is
so as we move forward
into this new Congress because it looks
like um looks like this week we're gonna
get uh and I said this the other day
we're gonna have a government shutdown
next year in September
next year in September we are gonna have
a government shutdown
it is likely to happen
because Republicans don't give a [ __ ]
about Americans they don't give a [ __ ]
they never have why would they why would
they start now
I don't give a flying [ __ ] about you
so they're gonna shut down the
government in September
Republicans know this Democrats know
this
that's why they're gonna get a
continuing resolution a CR by the end of
this week now I don't know if that one
will actually go to September or they'll
kick this past the holiday and make sure
to secure a CR till September
before the new Congress is sworn in
but the government will will probably
shut down in September
I told you this the other day this is
what is going to this is their [ __ ]
plan
now they'd like to shut it down now as
they take power
which is even more bone-headed really
honestly let's [ __ ] do that let them
[ __ ] them well if they're gonna shut it
down anyway shut it down now [ __ ] them
it'll all it'll only display how inept
they are at [ __ ] policy and
government in general
they [ __ ] suck at it
this is why this is why they should not
be in power of anything nothing
they do not know how to govern they
don't know how to policy what's their
policy shut down government and the
laptop
think about it
what solution have you heard a prominent
Republican stand in front of a
microphone and offer
what this morning Joe Biden's out
bragging about inflation being down the
stock market being up
remember how it was supposed to crash
it was odd the stock market was gonna
crash in 2020.
you'll never you'll never see three
dollars 250 a gallon again ever
really [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
yes prices are still dropping
even as the holidays approach
as inflation goes down this holiday's
approach everyone told you what was
happening
we came out of a pandemic there is there
is a I don't know if you'd know this but
we live in a capitalist Society I don't
even know that I don't even know what
our economic system is but it's
capitalism
there was huge demand coming out of the
pandemic little Supply because of the
pandemic
and it caused a lot of strain on our on
our economic situation
it's just a damn good thing that in 2020
we decided to put Democrats into control
they're the only ones that know how to
handle a [ __ ] economy in the first
place Jesus Christ Our deficit is down
the most it's ever been under any modern
president
and Democrats are supposed to be the big
[ __ ] Spenders
they've had control
of the executive branch and the
legislative branch for the last two
years and the deficit is down Democrats
didn't talk about deficit once and
lowered the deficit
you you people out there that are still
[ __ ] voting for these goddamn Nazis
that don't give two shits about you your
family your economic situation or
anything that you're concerned about are
just [ __ ] duped by the by the elons
the Kanye's and the trumps
but it ain't gonna happen tomorrow these
people getting on the off ramp
and absolutely coming to grips with this
[ __ ] delusion
that they continue
it's not gonna happen tomorrow
it's gonna take us to keep pushing
we have to keep going we can't stop I
told you that all year last year or this
year excuse me I'm still I'm I'm
thinking it's 20 23 already [ __ ] it
we're almost there
foreign
[Music]
we're almost there
but the whole year of 2022 I told you
that the midterm was the most important
election of our democracy's lifetime and
you listened
gen Z listened
you took it seriously
you did the things that democracy do
which is pushed back on fascism
push back on authoritarianism
that's the design that's the intention
and it doesn't always work and it's hard
work it's hard [ __ ] work it's hard
work to agree with a lot of lefties
isn't it I'm telling you it's hard work
for all the people on the left the left
people who aren't [ __ ] Nazis at this
point is the left
it's hard to agree with everyone on
every single point but that's okay we do
not have to agree to be on the team of
democracy we don't gen Z understands
that better than any generation and I'm
happy to see it
I'm happy to see it that a generation is
coming to leadership in this country
because they are buddy they're coming to
leadership and they're going to be the
fastest generation to leadership in our
country that we've ever seen
because they give a God damn about our
democracy in our country they give us
[ __ ]
and that's why they'll be there quicker
than any other generation and that's why
I'm confident but we cannot we have to
support them we have to support each
other and we can't give up
we can't let down now
we have to lean in all the way in
this next election the 2024 election is
the next big
threat to our democracy's life
and we must
we must stay vigilant
it is time
now
to not be distracted
by what word Marshall they were texting
to try to overthrow our vote
who gives a [ __ ] which one they picked
whether it was right wrong or
indifferent they were trying to take
away your voice
they were trying to rip up and Shred the
Constitution because it stands in their
way
it stands in their way of their white
privilege
and keeping their white privilege
they know it we know it
it's time to get it out in the open
it's time to put some sunlight on this
[ __ ]
I think we're gonna do that today as
always on Tuesdays we have Texas Paul
Texas Paul is here he's in the Green
Room
I don't know he looks like he's um
he's in the Christmas spirit there
uh so we'll we'll bring Texas Paul on
after the break but Texas Paul is here
Gabe Sanchez is back today he's feeling
better I think from his uh
his covet booster I'm here for sure as
you know every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific two full hours
on YouTube Twitter and twitch and
simulcasting from the Midas touch
Facebook page do not forget if you're on
the minus touch Facebook page to go over
to my page at Tony Michaels at the Tony
Michaels follow us on Facebook also
don't forget to subscribe here on
YouTube
super important to subscribe here on
YouTube and follow us on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod and download every single
episode on Apple Spotify and Google
leave us a great review while you're
subscribing on your favorite directory
also there's still time
to get a great Christmas gift at
store.thetonymichaels.com
store.thetonymichaels.com
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty hoodies
sweaters t-shirts are going like
hotcakes so are the Ron DeSantis can go
[ __ ] himself this guy's gonna this guy's
gonna appear over the next few months
and there's gonna be a infighting inside
a Republican party as these
as these polls shift away from Trump and
into Santa's Direction don't get it
twisted DeSantis doesn't have it in the
bag
because Donald Trump is the king of the
chaos machine
and he will rain chaos down on Ron
desantis's ass which I'm all for seeing
to be quite honest so go to store.beat
Tony michaels.com that store that the
Tony michaels.com get the Iran DeSantis
can go [ __ ] himself merch today you can
also go to tonymichaels.live that's
tonymichaels.live leave a tip there one
time tip or set up a monthly tip you're
the best audience in the world thank you
for all your support your shares
your comments everyone is here today in
the live chat on YouTube
give the moderators some love as well as
we get into the Christmas spirit as we
come into the holidays give them some
holiday love everyone stick around Texas
Paul it's Tuesday
right after this break
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
Boyer they're gonna need some pardons
over there for these members of Congress
Eve Sanchez is always on point with his
videos isn't he holy [ __ ] a jet
Texas ball joining us today it is
Tuesday he's in the Christmas spirit
ho ho ho Jingle Bells It's Beginning to
Look a Lot Like Christmas Texas Paul how
are you
I am wonderful I have missed you Tony we
haven't talked we haven't talked all
week man hey my wife made me a new mug
check it out oh did they do they taste
good in there do they taste good
delicious man I I hope everybody's
coffee is as good as mine I am in such a
good mood today you couldn't slap the
happy out my mouth oh [ __ ] no [ __ ] what
makes you happy today Texas ball oh man
I tell you what uh I don't know if you
caught it but I just did a new
commentary for Midas Touch about 040
March oh yeah the elevator flatulator
yeah yeah elevator flashulator you think
so you think she gets in elevators just
to fart in there you think that's what
the elevator I gotta get in there you
know yeah musk Mickey man must be I tell
you what they uh she's something else
man I I just ever since you put that
tweet out about Mass can't protect you
because you can smell farts we we I
think we did 20 minutes the elevator
flatulator from now on huh well I think
we did 20 minutes on the uh farting
underwear thing the other day was that
what was that three weeks ago I don't
know I lose track with these [ __ ]
seditious pieces of [ __ ] did you see
some of the video from her the other day
at this time
yeah what
do you know some dildos and butt plugs
at PBS and Target I had no idea
I I mean you know I I'm not opposed to
it I mean I I don't really know yes for
dildos and butt plugs but I'm not
opposed to people going and getting
their butt plugs and their dildos from
from CBS so here's the thing this is the
students here's the stupid [ __ ] about it
CVS and Walgreens or drugstores or
Walmart have always sold like lube and
[ __ ] condoms and all kinds of crazy
[ __ ] and they even have you know they
they have these things they call them
they call them massagers you know what I
mean if they're you either plug them in
or their battery operate they're
massagers right come on they've always
sold sex toys at [ __ ] at [ __ ] CVS
and [ __ ] this is dumb stupid [ __ ] I did
not know that honestly I knew about the
lube but I didn't know
Texas ball is like you goddamn right I
know where the Lubin condomile is in the
CVS it just it floors me that they so
are so hyper focused on [ __ ] like that
like what is it what does it matter to
you if they're profiting off butt plugs
and CVS for like what in that how does
it matter to you
and folks if you don't know the the what
we're talking about everybody's seen
this viral video but if you happen to
have missed it Marjorie Taylor green sat
in front of the young Republicans giving
us the elitist the elitist yeah Dead
Silence when she says this she says that
did you know that CVS and and Walgreens
sells butt plugs and dildos I mean she's
oh my God the room just went down now
Texas not Texas Paul um I don't know if
you know this but there are there are
some butt plugs that have dildos on them
so it's like an all-in-one type thing
you learn something new every day I I
know I I mean we can we can go look it
up and we can put it up on the screen if
we need to if I need to show you proof I
mean I you know I don't want the
audience I think I'm lying
I believe you Tony
now this is this is hilarious coming
from a person on the same stage she was
bitching about the equality of Marriage
Act how she's so oppressed because
because gay people is now codified that
they can get married which doesn't
affect her in any way shape or form
other than it [ __ ] offends her you
know her sensitive [ __ ] snowflakeery
but but here she is this is this is a
[ __ ] person who
is getting divorced because she can't
she can't handle being around other
people without [ __ ] them apparently
um there's rumors going around that
she's not only had sex with uh several
uh television hosts but it's possible
there's other members of Congress
there's other members of gangers and
then you know the Alex Stein 99 guy the
guy who sex your air was harassing AOC
on the capital steps yeah apparently
they um I mean the rumor is that they've
boned I mean if you want to and maybe oh
God damn it Tony maybe that's how I'm
just saying maybe that's how she figured
out that there were butt plugs at CVS I
mean she had to make a run to CVS she's
like maybe they have a mirror I don't
know and she just got lucky she's like I
was lucky that they had butt plugs to me
I gotta I got a confession to make my
wife absolutely adores you she does I
woke up this morning feeling like
hammered [ __ ] she's throwing me all
kinds of medication and oh really is
that why you're happy-go-lucky get you
all drugged up one thing honey he's ear
raping me
every day I do it every day that's what
I'm here for no I mean I'm I'm all for
talking about butt plugs and dildos I'm
not scared of butt plugs and dildos like
Marjorie Taylor green and Republicans
you know I I believe that this is more
projection though really honestly it's
more projection
um I I can only imagine what kind of
[ __ ] weird [ __ ] that Marjorie Taylor
green is into can't even imagine some of
the weird [ __ ] that she's probably into
you know she's been to a tantric sex
guru that she had an affair with so yeah
I imagine it gets a little a little
freaky you know buck tooth Barbies
bedroom well I don't know maybe she
likes the farting you know that's a
thing too that's kind of a kink which
I'm not here to Kink shame anyone hey if
you like farts hey no problems whatever
butt plugs farts whatever you want to do
I'm not going to shame you here's what
I'll tell you though for that for that
[ __ ] to get up on stage and to talk
about the sanctity of marriage and all
this nonsense about how you you know
christ-like and sure white Christian
nationalism and all this [ __ ] in her
religion and all this nonsense to
[ __ ] dehumanize and denigrate gay
people because they loved each other and
they want to get married and somehow
that affects her sanctity which there is
none to her she's a [ __ ] liar she's a
[ __ ] fraud and honestly
um it just pisses me off pisses me off
that she can stand up there in front of
a bunch of [ __ ] New York Elites
that's what she who she was talking to
is New York Coastal Elites because
that's who they are
Elon Musk which was he was the richest
man in the world not anymore because
he's a [ __ ] idiot
that guy that guy is simping for
Republicans right now the richest man
richest man in the world is simping yeah
well I'm sure once uh game Sanchez
joined us he he won't he won't want to
talk about anything else but there's
method to that Madness by the way it's
failing horribly but there's method to
that Madness well the reason why it's
failing is because our narrative is loud
and proud and and it's and we're not and
they haven't they haven't come to grips
with that we're not going to stop this
they thought we would stop after 2020
they stopped they thought we would stop
after 2022 we would lay down our arms
they would have some big red wave and it
would shut us up [ __ ] that [ __ ] I am not
going to shut up and we should not shut
up and we should keep pushing forward to
make these [ __ ] crawl back
underneath their rocks now rather than
they don't destroy Twitter or anything
else that's up to them yeah you got to
Pat yourself on the back a little bit
brother because the reason it used to
work and it used to work this [ __ ] that
they're pulling today right used to work
it doesn't work now because we exist
10 years ago we did not no you know I
don't know about you but 10 years ago I
was doing something totally different I
was still political I was still in
politics but I wasn't doing this
ten years ago there was nobody screaming
back into a microphone about this
[ __ ] telling people hey Elon Musk is
doing this for a reason Elon Musk is is
starting the narrative for the [ __ ]
Republicans to start this investigation
[ __ ] and that's why he keeps
throwing these [ __ ] conspiracies out
there in the [ __ ] twit files you know
it there is a reason for this I mean
they know I mean
they know how badly this [ __ ] stunk
when they put it out they did they saw
the same material we did
you know they knew it was [ __ ] when
they put it out the point is they were
trying to be a meat tenderizer they were
trying to start this ball rolling
because the Republicans Lauren bobert
was pining about this the other day why
aren't we on the offensive why are we on
our heels well I tell you why you're on
your [ __ ] heels because you're
[ __ ] lousy you're a sorry human being
and you've got people out there [ __ ]
talking about it right we're pointing it
out to everyone
and we're going to keep pointing it out
to everyone and anyone who will [ __ ] God
bless you Tony much it it just it it
just uh you know again uh it kind of
gets on my crawl when people are like oh
I'm Gonna Leave Twitter and you know
it's not you know it's not worth the
fight and blah blah blah and it's like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about look
what we did in 2022 they gerrymandered
the [ __ ] out of the house district
gerrymandered the [ __ ] out of him and
they barely [ __ ] won Jesus Christ it
was just announced this morning just the
speaking of Lauren Boward it was just an
announce this morning after a mandatory
[ __ ] recap that she barely won her
race
barely won so I'm telling you folks I'm
telling you folks that every [ __ ]
vote counts every [ __ ] message every
time you say something every time you do
something every time you talk to someone
it doesn't have to be into a microphone
like me in Texas Paul do it can just be
someone in your community your family
your friends it matters it matters when
you're pointing these things out because
not everyone is interested in in
democracy and in government and politics
as we are but they must know about this
stuff they're much more concerned with
who Tom Brady's going to be throwing the
football for and if he's going to be
throwing the football they're much more
concerned about that but you have to put
this stuff in front of them you have to
we've got to get these people in this
country to realize that that that to
have to have the discussion and the
debate about who's going to throw the
football for what team we have to have
democracy first that's just what we got
and I would love to throw some Kudos out
to your audience I really would because
you know I'll be folks I'm one vote Tony
is one vote yeah we work we bust our
asses off Tony's here every day [ __ ]
slapping it man he's out here busting
his ass to get the word out
I do my Sunday show I'm all over social
media yeah we do that but you folks made
this election happen because we're two
votes sitting here you're looking at two
votes that's it you folks made this
midterm happen you folks kept the
[ __ ] Republicans from dirting us in
as a country and you damn well should be
proud of that you should be proud of
that and that's I don't know if you've
noticed this this massive push on social
media to put the [ __ ] stains in your
feeds your Twitter feeds your Facebook
your everything the [ __ ] trolls are
like falling from the trees that is to
try to get that taste out of your mouth
that taste of Victory Is it is it the
taste of butt plugs and dildos from CVS
I'm just just I'm just asking I'm just
asking you know I want to go back to
the butt I'm very interested in the butt
plug dildo talk I'm just saying look the
reason why they're bringing that [ __ ] up
though the reason why Marjorie Taylor
green is bringing that [ __ ] up is
because they don't have any good policy
ideas even even if even if they had a
way to a policy idea of why it's bad to
have butt plugs and dildos inside a CVS
they don't have a solution they only
have problems to present that is it and
they're not even real problems it's all
[ __ ] it's all made up it's all
nonsense almost like every single
[ __ ] thing that Elon Musk has been
concentrated on on publishing on Twitter
whether it's through him or some stupid
[ __ ] half-assed journalist or claims
to be journalists that's not how
journalism works by the way I don't know
if you I don't know uh Texas Paul did
you see how they dropped these uh Mark
Meadows text messages from 34 and other
Congress members I know it's like 2 000
text messages that's journalism that's
actual journalism okay that is how you
[ __ ] drop big pieces of information
for the American people to see and to
and to consume and to figure out what
the [ __ ]
that went on
not the way that Elon Musk and Matt
taibi and Barry Weiss are doing it that
is hackery [ __ ] hackery and and it's
supposed to be hackery folks that's why
and I I know I know a lot of people
don't like when I say this and they
don't like when I'm like hey we need to
politicize every single turn folks we
are the accurate I'm the hackery I'm
supposed to be the rodeo clown that's
the whole point the whole point is I am
the rodeo clown that's the whole
[ __ ] point
they it works it has worked for years
for them
like Texas Paul said to have the rodeo
to have the circus it works that's what
the Elon thing is and I know Texas Paul
and I know when we get Gabe Sanchez on
here we're going to talk about the rodeo
and the [ __ ] circus that is at
Twitter right now but we are the circus
we are the hackery that's the whole
point and the in Texas Paul is right
because we're here because we're yelling
and screaming and we're doing our circus
they don't know what the [ __ ] to do
because there's never been a circus on
the left wing never they're always like
oh let me let me get my my stack of
statistics and read you statistics get
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] you
do not need a whole stack of Statistics
to make a decent argument for decent
income for [ __ ] decent [ __ ] Health
Care not going broke over medical bill
to not go broke because you want to
[ __ ] get an education to get a career
in this in this country so you can have
decent income you want to be able to
raise your family buy a house buy a car
without [ __ ] happening give away your
goddamn whole [ __ ] life
so so if that's what you want to do you
don't need statistics to make an
argument for that you just don't you
don't and one reason why you don't is
because what you do is you put actual
people who are interested in policy in
charge of policy like we have right now
we have it right now Joe Biden is more
interested in policy than almost any
other modern president that I've seen
and he's doing a great job he's
successful yeah is he not getting as
much as maybe you want sure whatever but
that that doesn't [ __ ] matter you
can't you can't concern yourself with
that you can't concern yourself with
that what you got to do is make sure
that the threat
crawls back underneath this rock
speaking of threat We Got Game Sanchez
with it
all right be Amigo that the threat is
over Gabe Sanchez you got your um covet
booster how you feeling my friend good
good are you feeling like Branch
covidian type thing is it I feel I feel
like I'm running on 7g right now oh
really so this is like an upgrade from
5G to 7g there was like you know when
when when like a company is like hey
look our website's gonna be down for
like this period of time we need to do
some maintenance yeah it's kind of what
happened when I got the booster and then
now my boom we are ready to go we got a
firewall up we've got no one strong yeah
the Signal's pretty strong great great
money to cancel my phone bill honestly
what do you need a phone for if you got
7g right implanted you right hey I gotta
ask you I gotta ask you speaking of
technology and people who claim to
invent technology uh we were talking
about Elon Musk earlier and I know I can
see you say uh Elon is a fool and I know
um I know I know you you've got it um a
lot to talk about with Twitter what's
the update honestly I am not gave a [ __ ]
about Elon I haven't been paying
attention it's all nonsense it's all
dribble it's all [ __ ] I mean I gotta
watch some of it because I gotta
commentate on here but I'm kind of
relying and leaning on you to pay
attention to this [ __ ] fool what's
going on over there Twitter I know Texas
ball has been paying attention to
because he was talking about how it's
all intentional this is all on purpose
tell us about it yeah yeah I mean like
if you were if you were to compare let's
say time stamps I'm not gonna be one of
those conspiracy people like oh tin foil
hat but if you were to look at
if you were to look at the time stamps
of when certain events were happening
and also when the Twitter files were
released you might begin to question
certain people's motives right like you
might say Oh look The Trump organization
has been uh has been found guilty of 17
counts and then within that wait wait
were there were those criminal counts
I'm just checking those were okay
criminal gowns I just want to make sure
but we found within the same hour
uh I think it was Twitter file
supplemental I think is what it was you
can't even keep track anymore I know
they're on you need to make just a big
[ __ ] board with like string attached
and all that [ __ ] hey honestly I mean
I'm I might make a video
it's a connection of a bunch of red
string and newspaper and people's names
but what happened was I think it was I
think it was Twitter files supplemental
and it was the oh my God we're gonna
find out more and Barry Weiss dropped
her jaw on the floor and all this
[ __ ] I think it was that one or
maybe it was 2.0 it really did it really
did go over like a wet fart in a white
thong did it oh yeah I mean every every
because what happens is every single one
they've released is typically timed up
with something so uh yesterday was a was
a big example of this but it was like
Twitter two Twitter Twitter supplemental
or 2.0 was when Trump uh organization
was indicted with 17 counts found guilty
then it was like within an hour boom
that one comes out now yesterday was a
great example of very odd timing so the
night before Elon Musk goes to somehow I
don't know if he got an invite or if he
just showed up and they brought him on
stage but he was at Dave Chappelle's
concert in the Bay Area
and what happened as a result is he goes
on stage and I'm sure everyone has seen
the videos of him being like trying to
talk but everyone's booing
and he says oh he got [ __ ] boo yeah
and I tried to explain it yesterday that
and and forgive me the cell phone camera
it was so far away that the one that
everyone was kind of circulating around
of course he was deleting accounts I'm
sure that's what you're going to talk
about right right but but here's the
thing is that cell phone camera is not
designed to pick up sound in a in a big
huge Stadium like that it's just not
designed to pick it up and it's only at
certain points that you can actually
hear through the microphone the booze
right
um but it's real go ahead sorry and so
so yesterday was a good example so the
that morning early that morning or late
that night uh when when when he was
there but yesterday morning pretty much
video goes up it it just leaves itself
but somebody had made a copy and they
put it back on and they basically said I
don't know what happened to the original
account I can't find it anymore it's
just no longer there who knows what
happened then people are like commenting
and saying oh I there was a post video
posted here it was removed which then
begins to think like oh wait why why are
these videos being removed right it's
very embarrassing moment for someone
especially who goes on stage and gets a
crowd worth of people booing
and you find out that within that same I
think within like it was like 9 30 or
something like that my time uh in the
morning in the morning it was right when
the show was starting right because I
was trying to find it while we were
doing the show yesterday I'm like where
the [ __ ] is this video because I was
looking for the small clip where Dave
Chappelle pulls him up and says here's
the richest man in the world and they
just start [ __ ] booing rare and it's
like eight or ten seconds it wasn't very
long yeah I said it to you that morning
I think right yeah yeah there's several
the [ __ ] is this thing there's several
different versions him saying I'm rich
[ __ ] which sounds like he's saying I'm
Rick [ __ ] you know there's multiple
angles but uh yesterday what ended up
this is why I found it so interesting is
because Twitter files 5.0 gets released
by Barry White we're already on fine
point aren't you [ __ ] me yeah we're
on 5.0 is this including the
supplemental yeah so it's like 6.0 I
guess technically so there's technical
Jesus right so there's six so far that
I've gone out but the thing that's here
is the videos go out and by 9 30 my time
uh Barry Weiss is like oh man 5.0 here
you go which is again a very odd timing
to be like oh why is this happening now
kind of arbitrary it wasn't any lead up
to be like here it comes
and I honestly believe when Twitter was
being flooded and trending with Elon and
Dave Chappelle and it was all just
videos of him getting booed
that I wouldn't be surprised if Elon was
like Hey Barry White is like [ __ ]
release this now as a way to counteract
what was being spread against him so
this is yeah this is one exam this is
one tweet because he he had to go in and
try to defend himself uh multiple times
yesterday about getting booed right and
trying to find excuses for why the
booing happened and this and that and
this is just one of them
uh well let me let me read it here let
me read it here
um
technically this is what Elon Musk
tweeted yesterday now he's deleted this
since it says technically it was 90
cheers and 10 booze except during quiet
periods
okay right
um which is what I was talking about
with the microphone on the camera right
and the reason why is because the
microphone on the camera is going to try
to pick up the sound around it as
opposed to the sound far away yeah and
that's why only when it gets quiet
around the microphone do you start to
hear the sound that's far away but
anyways
um he goes on to say but still that's a
lot of booze so he's admitting this and
and then this is the statement that I
think why he deleted this which I don't
know why he just didn't edit it out but
whatever I mean he's he owns this
[ __ ] thing he can do whatever he
wants which is a first for me in real
life
he's never been [ __ ] booed apparently
uh I guess when you when you have that
much money which he doesn't anymore when
you have that much money you can make
sure that No One's Gonna boo you yeah um
and and he goes on to say frequent on
Twitter it's almost as if I've offended
SFS which is San Francisco's unhinged
leftist but nah and then he deleted this
so well just a little side note to that
go ahead you know he's been he's been
before he even bought Twitter he was he
was in a in a death spiral we didn't
know it was a death spiral at the time
but he was spiraling downward uh his
stock was at that high of over 400. uh
yesterday restaurants
so yeah tomorrow [ __ ] brilliant
genius billionaire I mean
here here is the um here's yesterday's
um Market
um Gap and he's it's down to 162. is
that what you're talking about Tesla
right
yeah yeah well that's his only publicly
traded company there's the rest are
private right right it's even lower
today I think it's like 158 right now
is the stock market up and Tesla's down
is that the is that the case yes
um yeah I don't know I don't I don't
watch stock market it's no indication of
the American people to be honest it's
it's only about [ __ ] people like Elon
Musk and people who support his dumb ass
is an indication of it to be quite
honest but you know that's why I don't
[ __ ] batter you with [ __ ]
statistics and [ __ ] here on on the show
but but um this is important and the
reason why this is important not because
of the number because what Texas Paul is
saying the effect of it like because
really honestly doesn't this just
absolutely stomp a mud hole in any
confidence that any investor or anyone
would have and how smart Elon Musk is
this looks really cool also it puts a
hole in like when you've got so yeah the
NASDAQ and the s p are up today and but
if you were to look at this you would
also show that not only does it put a
hole in any investors confidence but it
also put a hole puts a hole in anyone
who's like oh he's the smartest uh
richest man in the world he's like well
actually he's not but not anymore that
was last week he was teetering and today
he definitely has dropped below that and
then to number two spot some people
think that he might drop into the number
four spot with the next few days which
would be I think below below can we get
him can we get him can we get him just
uh out of the top ten by the by New
Year's is that a good New Year's I mean
it's a possibility but a lot of people
think because I think right now you know
I mean number four and I apologize if
I'm stepping on Gabe I'm losing his
audio for some reason but um
this is all Elin this has nothing to do
with his products his services this is
all his stupid [ __ ] mouth he was a
talk about snatching Victory from the
jaws of defeat right that's what you
always want to do he's the [ __ ] polar
opposite of that this guy's a world hero
there's a war going on in Europe okay
red flag right there there's a war a
ground war going on in [ __ ] Europe
right now that never works out real well
okay right a hot Wars Rockets bombs and
[ __ ] yeah and Joe Biden is doing an
amazing job and I'll talk about that
later but anyways
Elon Musk is providing
internet services for soldiers in the
Ukrainian Army on the front lines
what a great [ __ ] thing for a guy to
be saying
what a great thing for a guy to be
saying you talk about marketing man
you're talking about free [ __ ]
commercials for life this guy was a hero
he sits down for lunch one [ __ ] lunch
with Vladimir Putin and he comes out and
butt [ __ ] the Ukrainian Army
this is all Elin destroying these
companies
I mean he he
and he has no [ __ ] sense who is who
his you know customer base is there's a
reason the CEO of of GM is not on
[ __ ] Twitter
okay she
there's an entire Council put together
to control the statements that come out
of the CEO's office she can't say good
morning without somebody saying well
who's she talking to what's going on
there okay yeah let's approve that good
morning statement I mean and there's a
reason for that it provides stability
people say oh well it's fake well it's
not fake
it's intelligence it keeps you from
doing a [ __ ] Elon Musk and Elin
cannot stop his [ __ ] mouth
he can't that's why this twit files is
failing so [ __ ] badly is it's coming
out of Elon musk's shop
are you saying he's a failure are you
saying he's a bigger loser than Trump
because it really feels like we're
getting in a competition of who's The
Biggest Loser it it really it really
does show you how much
because like as the Twitter files are
released right you find the first one
they're like oh looks like they have a
or at least had a policy in place for
non-consensual nudity right and
Reporting those things supplemental was
like oh there was a legal counsel in
place legal counsel was removed the
person who would be in charge of vetting
that type of information that was
released then you find out in 3.0 and
4.0 and 5.0 that they're they're talking
about oh how unfair Trump was treated
because they had a protocol in place
yeah a lot of people don't like Trump
but at the same time they're watching
the things that he was doing and watch
what he was saying oh and turns out he
did the thing that he was talking about
doing and luckily we did not allow that
to actually fully take place but all of
them are trying to act like victims and
be like oh my God Trump couldn't say the
thing and they were blocking Fox and we
were they were they were monitoring all
the election news and they were working
with Trump's Administration and Trump's
FBI and Trump's DHS keep in mind again
Joe Biden was not elected he was not in
office this is all president Trump's
Administration and his government that
was cooperating and working with Twitter
okay it wasn't just like a few people
who were like trying to run a coup
against the Republican party it was an
Administration and the government
agencies that were working directly with
the with Twitter
because they saw hey look they're
talking about these things or they're
saying these things about the election
or about overthrowing the government or
about covid I mean the fact that you
have a CEO who says my pronouns are
prosecute uh fauci which is like one for
what what are you Prosecuting fauci for
okay that's the first problem the second
thing is like Tony and I have talked
about this before like even
I think it was like episode 50 we talked
about it with uh with the uh my zealous
brothers from Midas Touch we said nobody
would know who fauci was nope wasn't for
Trump nobody who thought she was before
Trump and nobody who thought you was
before Trump because all of them knew
hey great we have a spokesperson that's
going to talk about this stuff they're
going to be the talking head the
president will talk about it as well but
then the person who's in charge of these
departments or in charge of handling an
outbreak or pandemic it's going to focus
on doing their job and focus on the the
public health because it's a Public
Health crisis and they should do what
their job is but Trump is like oh I
don't take any responsibility and it's
going to be Dr Burks and it's going to
be uh Dr fauci those are the people you
should really be asking and and it got
to a point where fauci was trying to do
his job and he literally opened up an
envelope got sprayed in the face with a
bunch of powder he didn't know if it was
uh if it was poison or if it was Anthrax
like you could easily look this up and
they talk about kind of his experience
and be like yeah got hosed down he got
isolated
uh he's had death threats against him
and his family and you see this so do
you see the same thing happen with the
former trust and safety Joel Roth who
was who has been dragged through by Elon
trying to push his uh conspiracy theory
that Twitter was the backbone of the
child pornography and trafficking ring
that was online which is basically they
suspended the committee that's tried to
stop that [ __ ] and that's the whole
point of it but right exactly and it the
crazy thing too is like you've again
you've got a CEO who is just commenting
like he's [ __ ] throwing [ __ ] in the
wind and seeing what happens and as a
result the Twitter files aren't [ __ ]
sticking like he wanted them to and so
he's using this as a way to personally
attack people like he was buddy buddy
with Joel Roth in the beginning when he
started and you always like yeah we've
got these things I run trust trust and
safety these are the protocols and
process we have in place and as soon as
he leaves and as soon as Joel says
I don't feel that Twitter is safe like
it once was then Elon goes okay boom
you're [ __ ] burnt right now and then
he attacks him where this guy has had to
leave his house he's had to leave his
house because of the death threats that
he's received from Elon stands and Maga
and if you can't tell me that the CEO
the sitting CEO who decided to on a whim
make a joke and get forced into buying a
company for 44 billion like a [ __ ]
idiot is now forcing a bunch of Q Anon
conspiracies disinformation on covid uh
uh spreading conspiracies about a
pedophile ring in the Twitter company it
is insane because you would think that
any company what I said would have some
sort of strategy but here's the thing is
it really that insane when when you when
you put it in the Periscope right if you
look through this through this through
the lens that Elon Musk believes Q Anon
right he he believes Q Anon full stop I
believe and he's been his he's been mind
[ __ ] by the right red pilled long time
ago but the cubanon is really mind
[ __ ] him and the main reason why is
because of the pandemic you know he was
all pissed off when he couldn't when he
couldn't [ __ ] work his his employees
like animals during the [ __ ] during
the [ __ ] pandemic he was pissed off
about that so much so that he was going
to pack up and move to Texas where he
could treat his employees like animals
but if you look through the periscope
of all this stuff that we're talking
about with Elon Musk and really the
Republicans in general Maga Elon sense
crypto Bros I mean the list goes on and
on and on with these people who are mind
[ __ ] and you look through the
Periscope of Q Anon it makes sense
though doesn't it Texas Paul don't you
think this makes sense when you look
through the Periscope that that maybe
Elon is a [ __ ] q and honor full stop
you know the guy's just it it's horrible
to watch something like this and this is
why I told you a couple weeks ago I I
have [ __ ] credibility I told you if
Elon Musk hired me I would [ __ ] save
his ass because I drive by his his
[ __ ] gigafactory here in Texas
whenever I go home I drive right by that
some [ __ ] and I see the cars in the
parking lot and those are not customers
cars those are employees cards this is a
[ __ ] disaster what's happening that
Elon is doing and it's just unfucking
acceptable and yes it's because he
surrounds himself with the same [ __ ]
people that surrounded Kanye West Kanye
West didn't invent all these [ __ ]
talking points that are falling out of
this [ __ ] mouth letters
if they were put there Elon Musk has a
limited number of people around him he's
got three major businesses
plus everything else you don't know
that's cooking on the sideline
the guy
who he socializes with who talks to him
is incredibly important
and this is what I kept trying to tell
the [ __ ] guy
you've got to stop listening to these
[ __ ] people you've got to
because you're [ __ ] destroying
everything
you need to step back you need to not
tweet for three weeks
you need ever again really I mean at
this point
no that has to really part in my in my
humble opinion has to be part of
[Music]
re-generating his image is that he's got
to stay on Twitter but he's got to take
a break and he's got to admit that he
was around some stupid [ __ ] people
and he's got to admit that he said some
stupid [ __ ] things but hiring Barry
Weiss of all [ __ ] people to be your
spokesperson Matt taibi is bad everybody
knows what Matt Tybee is very wise for
some [ __ ] reason has this error about
her that people like Bill Maher think
that she's [ __ ] intelligent she's not
she [ __ ] damn near flushed the New
York Times down the toilet her and her
little cabal or Brett Stevens and Maggie
Haberman and all these people you know
thought that they could they could brain
[ __ ] everybody and and just because they
said it we would eat it up
that's what Elon Musk is trying to do
he's had these people tell him this [ __ ]
so he brings in very [ __ ] whites of
all he's an idiot I hope you all have a
clip of of the [ __ ] screenshot she
puts up where she's she's trying to make
the point that Twitter is biased against
right-wingers right and then there's
a shot exactly lives of tick tock this
[ __ ] right-wing hate [ __ ] group uh
that that attacks gay people and trans
people and whatever has a [ __ ] banner
across the top of it that nobody can
take action against this [ __ ] group
you know she's a [ __ ] and he's
surrounded by [ __ ] morons right now
and the goddamn shame of it is this
isn't about Elon Musk it's not
it's about those tens of thousands of
[ __ ] employees that are about to lose
their goddamn jobs because so much of
what was all of Elon musk's goddamn
companies whereas that everybody thought
it was a [ __ ] Vulcan and turns out
he's a goddamn packlet you know I mean
it's just
and if you don't get that you don't
watch enough [ __ ] star uh star Star
Trek
well Gabe Sanchez you you sent this
tweet to me yeah so this is this is from
2020 and I remember it it's one of these
tweets that I will never forget and I
don't think a lot of people will also
forget either
but it was a moment where in May of 2020
Elon you know a lot of people were like
oh gotta take the red pill now here's
the thing I'm sure that Elon has had
these kind of you know conspiratorial
Vibes you know for a while now and this
is just one example where it's like oh
you gotta get woke you know or you gotta
wake up and all that [ __ ] and he
goes you know take the red pill right
and Ivanka goes taken and it's like okay
sit down okay please sit down please
and then Lily Wilkowski goes [ __ ] both
of you because as the co-creator of the
Matrix she can say that but also she
doesn't like the fact that this idiot
and this other [ __ ] idiot are trying
to co-opt this message that was in the
movie right which is also funny because
it literally goes against their own way
of thinking they are group they are
party taking the red pill would be
removing yourself from that [ __ ]
cluster [ __ ] of a of a [ __ ] show which
is the Trump Administration and the
Republican Party the people who want to
control you and want to suppress your
rights but again
in this in this moment of irony they
don't see that and they're like I'm
waking up I'm taking the red pill and
it's like that's the funny part is he
was on a tirade the other day about
wokeness and wokers and mother wokers
and he's like wake up so we can fight
the wokeness I'm like what what so do we
need to wake up or are we already woke
I'm confused as [ __ ] what woke is and
what they think it is I'm all [ __ ]
confused because it's the same thing
with the Rev Bill they've turned it
around but what what does it mean for
the audience Gabe Sanchez I'm I'm gonna
go take a piss and attend to my bed I
mean um
um
um but um I'm gonna go take a quick
break and while you explain to the
audience explain the audience what red
pill is because I think that's important
I'll be I'll be right back right so if
anyone remembers uh watching The Matrix
you've got the red pull red red pill in
in the blue pill right and you take the
blue pill given two options by by
Morpheus two Neo and he says okay if you
take your blue pill you go back into
your life you do the same mundane thing
you won't ever know this ever happened
you take the red pill and you wake up
and you experience this life-changing uh
uh moment where you're able to now see
the real you know the you pull back the
curtain and see who's kind of behind
there and that's what you know the
that's what he goes in and that's when
he you know unplugs and all that [ __ ] so
that's what's Happening Here is you've
got you've got Elon who just the other
day had a tweet that was or yesterday I
think that was like follow the bunny
which is another reference to the Matrix
and this idea that Elon is trying to
pull people with him down this Rabbit
Hole to follow him in this
conspiratorial manner which is oh look
Twitter was having this crazy pedophile
ring and they were letting it happen
Twitter was the reason that Trump didn't
get reelected which again Twitter does
not change the outcome of the election
and does not change the way in which
eight million plus people decided to
vote for one person in over another
person that person being Joe Biden
versus uh president Trump the other
thing too is the fact that they're
trying to make this idea that Twitter is
one big [ __ ] cabalen conspiracy that
they were the ones who were spreading
misinformation about covid and about
boosters and about the actual vaccine
and they were the ones who were trying
to suppress uh uh president Trump and
every other Republican person's voice on
Twitter no that's not it at all what
these Twitter files have exposed and
it's not some conspiracy it's not some
red pill moment or follow the [ __ ]
bunny what this is is revealing that it
was a private company and there were
corporate rules and protocols in place
and that capitalism I know capitalism is
the thing that drives that company hey
look if we're gonna you know be this be
this tool for billions of people and we
have uh 200 plus million daily active
users we need a certain process to
manage all of that content we need rules
regulation terms of service that you
agree to
you say okay great boom we have ways
that we work with government agencies if
something illegal is happening if they
anticipate something illegal is
happening we work with them because that
is the rule of law we are we are we have
to uh abide by the rules of the country
that we're in to make sure that we can
actually run there because at any point
like the EU is even the one that's under
under consideration for whether Twitter
continues to stay available but in
European countries it's even more than
that man you remember the two I mean
they were they are so bad at this
[ __ ] propaganda they put the Tweet
out that said on January 7th they moved
against Donald Trump
here's the date and they thought that
was going to be a big big [ __ ]
explosion January
this is in my Twitter files right this
is the twit files yeah
just remind me what happened on January
yeah what happened on January 6th
that might have made it relevant for a
company that provides a social media
platform to individuals to move Donald
Trump I mean because they had been
warning him about misinformation forever
they've been warning right-wingers about
coveted misinformation because we were
filling 18-wheeler trucks you know
reefer trucks full of dead [ __ ]
bodies for what a year and you know that
covered Twitter didn't come about this
over [ __ ] night I mean that's the
problem with somebody like Barry Weiss
is she's [ __ ] stupid and thinks that
her inner machinations are reality right
she cannot hold on to the fact that yeah
they moved on him on January 7th why
because he tried to overturn our [ __ ]
democracy on January 6th and the entire
[ __ ] world saw it and just because
you happen to not think that was a bad
thing because you're a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] human being
doesn't mean that the rest of the world
didn't [ __ ] see Donald Trump try to
destroy our goddamn country for his own
personal [ __ ] power and you want to
say Twitter's the bad guy in this [ __ ]
you people right and and even beyond
that I mean I just sent uh Tony a tweet
that literally the oath keeper attorneys
used president Trump's will be wild
tweet and other Communications as an as
a as a as a reason to which why Stuart
Rhodes and The Oath Keepers showed up on
January 6th right why they were under
the belief that they should show up on
January 6 and do what they did and
overthrow and try to overthrow the
government and storm the capital so you
know like Jordan says here goes on top
of that Oath Keepers you know attorneys
argued today that and Trump's will be
wild tweet brought the clients to DC on
January 6th but wait wait wait I thought
Barry Wise told us
that uh Twitter was unfairly picking on
Trump by suspending his account are you
telling me now that an actual person who
is who has gone through the files and
seen what was what was uh
what was you know tweeted or what was
shared what was communicated and then
the outcome was January 6th oh it's
crazy that also the [ __ ] attorneys
for The Oath Keepers the people who
wanted to overthrow the government are
arguing that these tweets that Trump
sent were the things that invited them
to come to Jan or to the Capitol on
January 6th so when you have Barry Weiss
who makes
who has a history of of errors in her
reporting at New York Times and wants to
blame the woke left and cancel culture
for why she was [ __ ] fired just
because the fact that she was
incompetent but she wants to blame
Twitter for the reason that Trump was
you know that he lost the election or he
was removed from Twitter God forbid it's
the things he said or the things he
spread or you know it was it was the the
misinformation and hatred that he was
brewing on Twitter as a communication
tool for other people within the party
and to bring this full circle back to 40
March what we were talking about earlier
Tony farting Mars the elevator
flatulator stood on stage
stood on [ __ ] stage and said had she
planned the Insurrection they would have
won with her and the human walking scab
Steve Bannon they would have won and
there would have been guns there well
one we have video of her leaving the
planning session in December 20th
talking about their great plan for
January 6th yeah
yeah she was part of the planning and
two there were [ __ ] guns there and
you lost anyways you [ __ ] loser [ __ ]
you lost anyways
but the point is they're trying to
rewrite this history right
they they think they're the daughters of
the [ __ ] Confederacy and that we
can't remember just last year you know
just a few months ago all of that Tony
all of the [ __ ] January 6 coverage we
did right like our people are gonna
[ __ ] forget this [ __ ] yeah well I got
the I got the clip here for saying the
statement about Steve Bannon but I wanna
I had to take a quick break to adjust my
Marjorie Taylor green I didn't know like
I said earlier I didn't know you know I
wasn't fully aware that that CVS uh sold
butt plugs I tried to go well I went
yeah so I was but I had to adjust I had
to adjust I'm going to call it Marjorie
take my Marjorie Taylor Green from now
on so I had to yeah when I went to
Village when I went to go get the old uh
the old booster yeah uh went through the
aisles ask the people did you see no no
they don't have them there no I did not
find it I did not find a dildo vibration
nothing I mean there's stuff that you
could plug your butt with for sure but
it's not an actual line you go to a
[ __ ] grocery store in the produce
aisle you can find a lot of [ __ ] to
stick together stuff that people are
like I don't know how it got up there
doctor right but I went to I went to CVS
and I could not I they they looked at me
and like what are you talking about man
and I was like ah never mind so I I I at
the Texas ball real quick before we go
to this clip now that we're talking
about butt plugs and orifices and all
this
um
so we discovered that you can live
stream to Pornhub and I've been trying
to figure out how we can get this show
on PornHub okay now I may or may not
have been on PornHub trying to figure
out how to get this show on PornHub the
other day
and there was there was someone sitting
on a um the the uh a bed post you know
what I'm talking about so I'm like why
is it such Why do we are we so concerned
that CVS is selling something that is
supposed to be intentionally placed
inside of you when people are putting
all kinds of [ __ ] that are not supposed
to be put inside of you inside of you I
mean this is kind of ridiculous but you
know I I digress on the whole
um butt plug bed post porn thing uh
let's let's go to Marjorie Taylor green
here and let's talk about let's see what
she says about how she would have won
which means overturn the Constitution
which is kind of weird here
um when she's talking about scamby Steve
Ben and let's let's listen come to
Washington
square is it on January 3rd I get
accused to use an Insurrection tours
which I thought was hilarious
again I said yesterday she couldn't find
the bathroom in the capitol does that
mean she was [ __ ] her pants maybe
that's why she's so infatuated with butt
plugs I'm just saying you gotta you know
yeah I I don't I don't actually use butt
plugs but I would imagine that would be
one unit and if anyone you know I'm
seeing some uh I'm seeing some comments
here as to what are alternatives to butt
plugs uh well Gene is straight up
scaring me man
eggplant oh my God Jesus Christ
grapefruit oh my God prickly pear holy
[ __ ] no thank you yeah these are these
are some uh a whole turkey what the [ __ ]
Jesus Christ
you all are wild man right now we got
the greatest audience in the world and
they love butt stuff okay let's continue
with uh speaking of butt stuff let's
continue with Marjorie Taylor green here
I [ __ ] love this show man I do I
swear to God I love this know I
organized
along with Steve being in here
and I'm going to tell you something if
Steve and I had organized that we would
have won
okay so obviously she's trying to get
you know a response from the audience
but literally she is saying Texas ball
she's literally saying
that if they would have won okay which
winning the Insurrection means no
Constitution is what it means that is
literally the definition of winning the
Insurrection is no Constitution because
it was a constitutional mechanism that
they were operating with the with the
joint session to certify the state's
vote that had already been certified so
they were wanting to overturn the
Constitution and she said she wanted to
win Jesus [ __ ] Christ well I'm
telling you the what that's all about is
one thing is one thing there's one rule
in politics there's there's one [ __ ]
thing that I can't fix for you in
politics I can I can dig you out of just
damn near any [ __ ] hole you know what
I'm saying I really can there's one I
can't
a [ __ ] L on your forehead yeah that
is an un breakable curse when they think
you're a [ __ ] loser and that's all
she's doing on that stage is saying we
weren't losers they were losers and
failed us and I would have won and you
people would have won and and we're not
losers you know if you wanted to really
translate that that's what that whole
[ __ ] speech is about and that is why
I I say repeatedly we have to destroy
this [ __ ] Republican party we have to
burn it to the ground and piss on its
[ __ ] ashes we have to we have to
because there's no one left in the
Republican party that does a postmortem
and says you know what
we're not attracting voters
let's fix that
no one yeah they're doubling down on the
things that are making voters walk away
from them in a prime example here in
this because she goes on to talk about
how they had had guns and pew pew pew
and cheese Yosemite Sam and all kinds of
stupid [ __ ] but here's the thing is she
is literally saying two different things
inside of her rhetoric okay on one hand
when she's out talking to rural country
folk she's like oh them are political
prisoners them Trump supporters that
tried to save our election and blah blah
yakity schmackity right and then she
goes to the New York Elites and says
those people are losers if we would have
done it we would have won those people
are losers they're worthless they didn't
those toothless rednecks couldn't get it
done without and and they definitely
couldn't get it done without us
and and again they're admitting two
things at once but they have no policy
absolutely [ __ ] none no policy
whatsoever to either prevent what
happened or change the system that's
that is the difference between people
who want to govern and people who don't
want a government so they can control
you I don't I don't know how I can't
explain this even further the Republican
party has been so steeped in this big
government stupid [ __ ] for years that
people believe that big government is
designed to control you no government us
we the people are the government to
design so the elitist and a few and
authoritarians don't control us you dumb
[ __ ] us
let me chime in here man you're you're
all absolutely 100 on it and Gabe back
me up here I always am I always on this
side on on this side over here
you have Joe Biden which I owe a
terrible apology to because I really
thought he was going to be this right of
Sinner Democrat that was going to this
guy is [ __ ] crazy effective crazy if
we have a land war going on in Europe
and gas prices are coming down
inflation is coming down
that war is being contained and not
spreading across Europe today today in
the White House they're having a signing
for the respect of Marriage Act in the
middle of this [ __ ] climate with
Republicans this [ __ ] gets
finished natural an actual bar an actual
bipartisan Bill 61 votes out of the
Senate there were 39 Republicans believe
it or not that voted for for to codify
uh gay and interracial marriage inside
the house which is like you're saying
amazing but that's what Joe Biden is
best at he can count votes he can count
votes Texas Paul and then and then do
you have policy action smart government
great diplomacy Brittany Greiner coming
home in the middle of a war we're on one
side the Russians are the are on the
other and he negotiated a high-profile
prisoner release in the middle of a
[ __ ] War right that's Democrats
over here you have hey let's look at
Hunter Biden's dick
and there's butt plugs in CVS and dildos
and dildos they you know I mean you have
we would have won the Insurrection we
would have destroyed let's cancel the
Constitution
that's over here
tell me anything else that's [ __ ]
over here do you need any other [ __ ]
picture anywhere dividing these two
[ __ ] parties and what the future of
America holds and who should be leading
right well I want to go back to the
Brittany grinder thing real quick and
Gabe I I don't know if you got a chance
to talk about the Brittany grinder thing
but I've been thinking about it a lot
um and I believe because you know you
can always tell when the right when you
know that there's a victory for
Democrats and Biden they automatically
they're like woke it's all wokeness you
know like their first thing is like
wokeness and mother wokers or or they
say uh I mean to the point about the
Insurrection if we were in charge and
the same thing happened with Brittany
Greiner if we were in charge we would
have gotten uh Wheeling out and it's
like first and I'll tell you here's what
I'll tell you about Wheeling I think
within the next 60 days Whelan's going
to be home now the one the one thing
that if you look at Brittany Greiner and
some of these other
um um hostages that we've gotten over
the years and you know they don't really
like to trade hostages and the one
reason why is obvious because if if a
foreign power especially our adversary
knows that we're willing to trade
prisoners that we have here in our
country that are Nationals of their
country and and and that we're willing
to trade for those they'll go find
Americans to to prosecute to trade okay
so that's that's one legitimate that's
one legitimate conversation that the
left and the right can have on this
discussion yeah but they're not so the
the the outright lie that there was a
choice between Greiner and Waylon it's
[ __ ] it's a lie he's not a marine he
was a marine at one time he's not a
decorated Marine that's all [ __ ]
that's a lie he and the LIE is that that
he was a spy I think that's a lie to
that's all [ __ ] I mean the other
thing is like if people want to bring it
up like he was dishonorably discharged
right but here's the three reasons yeah
but here's the thing he was a [ __ ]
spy just not for us he's a [ __ ] spy
they picked him up with 80 grand in cash
in his pocket and a thumb drive full of
[ __ ] Russian intelligence he was a
[ __ ] spy well right but he was but
again again that's where we get into
this this rough Battle of of trading
prisoners for prisoners we didn't used
to do that and and what I believe that
Russians wanted and what they want for
for Whelan is policy change which we
should not do that is something we
should not do we should not back off our
aggression
um and and and being
um on offense with Ukraine it because of
Putin's [ __ ] murderous uh uh um
violation of their sovereignty right we
should not change our policy in trade
um but I believe if you go listen to
Bill Richardson which if anyone doesn't
know who Bill Richardson just look it up
Bill Richardson was active in all these
prisoner trades
um and I believe that he's right that
Whelan is going to be coming home soon
um within I I believe probably within
the next 60 to 90 days that there are
prisoners that Russia wants we will
trade them and it's not just going to be
one it's going to be several but Putin
wanted Putin wanted this trade to be
with Brittany Greiner he was not going
to give up Wheeling easily
but now that he knows he can get
prisoners I think he's going to continue
to do this stuff he's going to continue
to negotiate because the word is that
the bite Administration is currently
negotiating not just for Whelan But the
teacher um His Name Escapes me too
um which is a whole nother [ __ ] ball
wax you don't hear about the [ __ ] the
teacher
um that that's been in custody over the
same sort of thing that Brittany Greiner
was in custody well also it it does show
you each time that they want to be like
well if we were you know and it's like
okay fine let's play that scenario out
how would that have happened and they're
like well okay president Trump would
have done this in 2018 he's like okay
well he had the opportunity he was in
office from until 2020 he could have
easily you know negotiated this and you
know well John Bolton John Bolton said
that there was it's possible and he was
he was the NSA right it's possible that
they were offered the trade right with
Waylon and they didn't take it but what
but what they've come out of this is you
know Trump goes on to truth social and
he says oh I you know I would have
totally done this if I had the
opportunity blah blah blah more news
comes out and now he's got a kind of
back pedal and be like oh yeah okay
there was a deal
and I turned it down so now it totally
just [ __ ] puts out the Flames of the
of the right saying well if Trump was in
power he would have done it and it's
like okay well he had the opportunity to
do it but he didn't do [ __ ] and when he
did have the opportunity he said nope
not going to take the deal so this whole
argument that he if he had the
opportunity he would have totally done
the deal but he didn't do the deal
because he had the opportunity he said
no I'm not going to do it well but
that's that's the point though is that
they anytime they fail they blame
something else wokeness or butt plugs
right right like they're always blaming
something else they're always blaming
something else uh Texas Paul you sent a
message about Marita boutina is enter
and then he say her name um the reason
why they didn't exchange hers because
she got out of prison and they didn't
want her running around courting all
these [ __ ] Republicans destroying our
national security that's why they booted
her back to Russia sent her backpacking
because
um she was infiltrating the NRA in the
Republican party at its core and got
nothing for her right well they just
sent her home didn't trade her back just
sent sent this little [ __ ] Russian
spy home to be greeted with [ __ ]
flowers now she has a a gig it's a loser
[ __ ] show I don't know if you ever
follow any Russian television but I
watch these [ __ ] she's got the worst
show I've ever seen in my life she I
mean it's horrible but it's her pension
it's a Russian pension you know they
gave her an apartment they you know and
we got nothing for we didn't get Paul
wheelan we didn't get any of the dozens
of people that you have no [ __ ] idea
have been arrested in Russia that are
American citizens that we need to bring
home
none of them and and speaking of Maria
boutina I don't know if you know P I'm
sure obviously you guys know this but I
I curious if the audience obviously
remembers or knows this is
the ex-lover of Maria boutina
is the former CEO because I know I know
Overstock got real [ __ ] butt hurt
that we were talking about the CEO of
Overstock but he's the former Overstock
uh CEO and his name might sound familiar
because he was brought up during the Jan
six uh hearings right wait was he in the
White House during January 6th was that
that guy that was the other yeah that
was one of the other guys that were in
other guys the other guys uh what's it
hers
in
or the other thing or the guy or the
thing are we talking which guy are we
talking about the one corrupt guy or the
other corrupt guy it's hard to know
Trump right now it's Patrick Byrne the
former CEO of overstock.com turns out
yeah I mean like you know it's also
crazy to think that at one point we had
the [ __ ] my pillow CEO the former
Overstock CEO we had all these retail
people who were saying yeah overthrow
the government that's what you got to do
we got to put in martial law which by
the way martial law was spelled as as
the we found in the text messages uh to
Mark Meadows was also spelled the same
way which incorrectly not spelled
m-a-r-s-h-a-l-l is the same way that
[ __ ] uh Mike Lindell spelled it wow
he was pushing Marshall place for
Marshalls the retail store in their
heart yeah I don't know maybe that's
what it is but Marshall amplifiers is
missing a really big one here they
should sell Stacks amplifiers Stacks
that are called the mar martial law
yeah that's right well you know you know
who else is martial law you know who
else is martial law do you remember
Marshall Dillon you remember that Texas
Texas fall do you remember yeah I know I
know you remember that the audience
I I know you remember that do you know
Marshall Dillon is
I know you do but I'm asking Gabe Gabe
you know Marshall Dylan no no you don't
know okay good well not good but I mean
you know it's not surprising it's not
surprising yeah he's gonna make Marshall
Mathers I mean does that count well
there's another Marshall that might be
able to benefit from from the martial
law statements I don't know maybe this
is a money-making scheme but you know
what Gabe was saying here is actually
pretty goddamn important I I mean you've
got this this group uh of people Peter
Thiel Byrne uh you know [ __ ] Mike
Lindell and and they are really
controlling this messaging these are the
people to tie it back to Elon Musk these
are the people that are mind [ __ ]
Elon Musk these are the kind of people
he sits with in [ __ ] Colorado in his
goddamn ski resort it's sipping [ __ ]
hot toddies with these are the people
that [ __ ] in his brain and it matters
folks it [ __ ] matters
I said mind [ __ ] but [ __ ] in his
brain that's pretty good
um you know the other thing too is with
this uh mind [ __ ] thing is the uh
the story about the 34 members of
Congress texting Mark Meadows uh just
you know snowballing coup plots and that
the way you saw it that's why I saw it
I'm like are they were they just like
hey what about if we try this hey what
did we you know you know we didn't get a
problem right when you get a problem
like you can't you go to get your
coveted booster you go to CBS you think
you're going to be able to pick up a
butt plug along the way and then you go
there and you go on the aisle there's no
[ __ ] butt plugs you know the
Republicans are lying to you you really
need that butt plug for your day off
because you know you're not gonna feel
so good so you want to you know make
sure to excite yourself with a butt plug
and you just don't have access to it you
gotta you know you gotta maybe you gotta
text some people right Gabe is that what
you did and say hey CVS didn't have the
butt plugs is there another location see
there's your snowball
[Applause]
and then I've got my parents game why
are you asking about that you know
I'm just saying this sounds familiar
what is this uh Reuters article that you
sent me so this is uh something Kailyn
uh brought up to me last night and it's
all it actually ties back to Elon too
um this is all part of the same
messaging yeah yeah it's all about using
this platform to to stoke uh hatred soft
Coos maybe yeah I mean here's here's one
that she actually quote tweeted because
I remember seeing this before
so
this is uh basically what what Kalyn is
arguing here and I think she's pretty
spot on is
are people you are people watching this
you know especially Republicans and seen
this as a way in which they can say
oh great we know what we can do right we
know what we could do again we know how
we can retry this right
um you've got people in the streets of
Brazil and you've got Elon being like oh
I've seen a lot of concerning tweets
about this [ __ ] you know
um these tweets are real and this is
yeah this is this is again Elon Musk the
CEO over almost two weeks ago right uh
you know trying to have a conversation
or not have a conversation but he's
interacting with other people and again
stoking this idea about some narrative
you know instead of him actually knowing
the facts or you know actually being on
the ground or I don't know in some sort
of political government position to
actually have the Insight he's basically
just just like all of the other things
he's running off assumptions that people
make like he said I haven't read the
Twitter files so all of his reactions
are based on other people reacting
online they're all assumptive of what
other people say like oh this is a big
breaking thing and then he says I
haven't actually read the Twitter files
but this is an example he here where
he's using Twitter
to stoke other violence and hatred and
so you've got a you know using or
allowing those right-wing candidates in
Brazil to tell lies on Twitter is
another example of this and especially
when you're like oh yeah free speech
right and it's like this is the liberal
reason why the the government agency is
under the Trump Administration went to
Twitter and said hey people are saying a
lot of [ __ ] and we need to figure out we
need to track these people down and we
need to uh triangulate where the
conversations are happening so we can
identify who these people are
and under Elon he's like yeah whatever
you know it's like you could say
whatever you guys want and like what
what's the worst that can happen you
know because that's that is the Chaos
Agent mentality that that Elon has
toward all this whether it's I bought
this to literally drive it into the
ground and shut off this communication
Channel or he bought it and was like
well [ __ ] it if I can't have it for what
I wanted or whatever then no one can
have it right well and you might as well
amplify the alt-rights message in the
meantime because that Brazil [ __ ] that's
all that's all Bannon that's all ban and
fodder that's all ban and narrative all
of it it's all right yeah absolutely
absolutely
actually you know you've got you've got
Miller down there that works for Bandon
is down there actually part of this
these These are this is literally an
extension of our politics and what what
Gabe is saying is so [ __ ] spot on and
why I [ __ ] do this folks it may seem
like Madness but really this is on my
mind when I'm saying the things that I'm
saying when I'm talking about [ __ ]
farty March and all the [ __ ] that she
says and I am cramming that [ __ ] down
the [ __ ] toilet it is because of
stuff like this because you've got Kerry
Lake in this country right now has
repeatedly made statements to try to get
her followers to do this very [ __ ]
thing that you're seeing in Brazil
she is bluntly without and and we have a
real problem in this country we really
do we really love the rule of law and we
like but it's going to bite Us in the
ass if we don't get a little bit [ __ ]
stiffer you know they tried this [ __ ] in
Peru they busted them and threw him in
jail [ __ ] immediately they tried this
[ __ ] in Germany Germany has seen this
[ __ ] before
they immediately rested arrested the
[ __ ] that were talking just
like Kerry Lake yeah this is just the
other day the investigation and they did
the investigation after they were in
jail they got the tips they got the
basic information and they acted right
we do the [ __ ] opposite we let these
people stand out here and scream this
[ __ ] the whole [ __ ] time we're doing
an investigation and run their defense
through the court of popular opinion
instead of throwing them in [ __ ]
Kerry Lake should be in jail right now
for the [ __ ] that she was saying she was
literally inciting violence directly and
unabashedly right to overthrow she wants
to overthrow the election in Arizona who
gets hurt be damned that picture you see
in [ __ ] Brazil is what they want here
and this is why we do it folks this is
why we do it we're protecting when I say
we're protecting our democracy yes I'm
not the soldier I'm not the cop on the
street but I am the [ __ ] guy that is
batting this propaganda down wadding it
up and shoving it down the [ __ ]
toilet where it deserves to go
this is what Tony Michaels does this is
what Gabe Sanchez does this is a [ __ ]
War you're seeing happening right here
it is a war of information
the only difference being I guarantee
you can go back and Google any [ __ ]
thing that any of us said
and it is spot on
back over here with the Republicans they
make this [ __ ] up look at the [ __ ]
twit files
well and it goes back to a lot of these
Talking Heads here's another one Matt
Walsh is trending right now I guess it's
because of this tweet here
um this is not too this I mean obviously
this all this this most likely stems
from Elon saying right the pronouns are
a project
for what and and again there okay so you
remember we just had an election in in
Pennsylvania in this country it was a
governorship you remember that do you
remember how um Pennsylvania not just
said no but hell no to the [ __ ]
Mussolini mastriano
um this guy in his closing argument in
the Pennsylvania race was about pronouns
he literally was going around the state
accusing the schools
of playing pronoun games now if you look
at what pronoun games are what he's
talking about is like flash cards to
learn words like they and them he she
her him have you ever tried to have a
conversation without using pronouns well
it is a little complicated in the
English language
um Now Matt Walsh again I'm not going to
read his dribble here if you want to
[ __ ] read it just read it on the
screen the point is this this goddamn
bigot this goddamn bigot is taking and
again this is why when Texas Paul says
this is intentional this is the drip
drip drip intention of it Elon Musk
didn't [ __ ]
basically uh ostracized people who want
to put pronouns in their bio right
because it's their [ __ ] choice you
get to write whatever in their bio that
you want to put you get that you get to
tell people how you want how you want
them to refer to you [ __ ] we do it all
the time you got nicknames you got
[ __ ] shortened names I mean Jesus
Christ Texas Paul is your first name
Texas for crying out loud it's really
[ __ ] it's really dumb [ __ ] that that
we have to do this stupid [ __ ] where
they're so offended by a [ __ ] word
because that's really what Matt Walsh is
is he's offended by a word but the thing
is it's all intentional the found she
thing was intentional the pronoun thing
was intentional for me Elon Musk and the
intention is to get these dumb
[ __ ] all stoked up in their
snowflakeedness because they're a bunch
of [ __ ] weak pieces of [ __ ] and they
get all butthurt about [ __ ] words and
they just can't stop typing in their
bigotry over [ __ ] words because
they're scared what's this uh tweet you
sent me here so this is the one that uh
so there's the exchange that happened
between
um Elon and Senator uh or between and
Scots Kelly right
um
and it was all over it started from the
prosecute fouchy one right and
uh Scott Kelly was like do not
um
don't mock right do not mock do I make
fun there's no reason to do that
especially I have to stop you there you
know who Scott Kelly is right yeah Scott
Kelly's not a center Scott Kelly is a
twin brother of Mark Kelly right right
yeah I said that's what I said I said
Senator first and then I was like oh
Scott Kelly I just I yeah I just wanted
yeah
um you know space man actual space man
right he's an actual actual space dude
yeah actual dude who uh knows the
science
yeah in this exchange you know he says
you know Elon please don't Mock and
promote hey torta uh already
marginalized and at risk of violence
members of the lgbtq plus Community they
are real people with real feelings
furthermore Dr fauci is a dedicated
public servant whose sole motivation was
saving lives like again literally Dr
fauci his whole job is to save lives and
if he could just focus on doing that
instead of being the scapegoat for
Donald Trump
then life would have been much easier
but obviously Trump always needs a Fall
Guy and needs someone to blame and Elon
the audacity to come in and says I
strongly disagree forcing your pronouns
upon others which nobody is doing nobody
is forcing anything that's like if you
were to say hey be married or something
right or or even like that's like hey my
name is Gabe and then the person's like
whoa whoa you can't force me to say your
name no I can't force you to do anything
but it would be nice if you could call
me by my name he says this all the time
in text messages he's like will you quit
call me dip [ __ ] and call me Gabe and
I'm like okay anyways and I'm just
kidding but it says you know forcing
your pronouns upon others when they
didn't ask and implicitly ostracizing
those who don't is neither good nor kind
to anyone as for fauci he lied to
Congress and funded gain of function
research that killed millions of people
not awesome in my opinion okay big uh
[ __ ] red flag here is that again no
one is forcing their pronouns on anyone
they put it in their bio because they
say hey if please just call me by this
if someone says it then they say oh
actually I go buy this it's not [ __ ]
hurting anyone it's not forcing on
anyone you could also completely avoid
calling a person she he her him and just
call them neutral and call them they
them crazy I know which you already do
in the English language
but Elon wants to [ __ ] complain about
this [ __ ] and wants to make a big deal
about it when it's not
but it's what Texas Paul is saying it's
all intentional it's intentional
the irony of this all is the fact that
Elon has a trans daughter well do you
really think do you really think Elon
gives a [ __ ] about anyone but himself
but what it does tell you what it does
tell you is that even elon's daughter
who turned 18 changed her name and her
gender through the LA courts uh system
out here out here in L.A and uh her
mother
supportive Elon she literally said I
don't want to I don't want anything to
do with him in shape name or form I want
to [ __ ] leave him the idea that you
would be like I'm gonna I'm gonna remove
myself from the Richest Man or former
richest man the billionaire
because I don't want anything to do with
him because I can only imagine what it
was like growing up
for her to have a guy who just made
jokes and mocked uh pronouns and that
group of people to be like my dad
doesn't even see me the way that I want
to be seen so I want to [ __ ] this guy
and get rid of him so like that's that
tells you who that kind of guy is he
still makes these jokes even after his
daughter was like no dude I'm out now
yeah but you know what that that's a
tactic that's a tactic that uh just real
quick that's a tactic that's this whole
argument about pronouns is to change the
argument from what the argument should
be we're talking about lgbtqi rights and
being treated it's just like Roe v Wade
they want to the tactic there is to
change the argument they want to argue
what the what is the line what is the
line for an abortion well actually the
argument is who draws the [ __ ] line
right and they want to change us from
that argument and if they can just
change us from that argument they win
they win because our argument is stay
the [ __ ] out of our business their
argument is no we get to be in your
business and if we change the argument
from who gets to draw the line to where
the line is they've already won and it's
the same thing with this [ __ ] pronoun
situation if we're arguing about [ __ ]
pronouns they're winning
they're winning
the fact is
lgbtqia People Are People period
Americans they deserve rights that's why
I say don't give a [ __ ] about pronouns
don't don't who gives a [ __ ] if if
someone
mispronounce you tell them to [ __ ] off
[ __ ] off you obviously don't give a [ __ ]
about anybody but yourself you're an
indecent piece of [ __ ] and you don't
even have the decency to listen to what
what my what my my existence is so [ __ ]
off and literally if if we could stop
getting so goddamn upset and [ __ ]
pissed off about someone doing this or
someone doing that on the left just tell
them to [ __ ] off [ __ ] you [ __ ] off I'm
done with you I don't need to have you
in my [ __ ] even in my space even I'm
done and get the [ __ ] out but but this
all goes back to you again your
messaging point and you sent me a link
here at Texas ball because
um this Brazilian messaging thing is
super important and I think that's what
you're trying to uh make a um a point
here with this
um yeah story here do you recognize the
guy in this [ __ ] picture do you
recognize the guy in this one looks like
he looks like a thumb to me yeah they
call him the thumb
big guy the Trump Administration big
pushing out bannon's agenda he you know
all the all the wild Trump was in office
this guy could get in just about any
[ __ ] door because of his
relationships
this guy's down in [ __ ] Brazil
working for bolsonaro all of the [ __ ]
that's going on in Brazil right now
comes from this [ __ ] right here
and it is the same Cesspool that still
that is here that is here it's like it's
like it's like they want to talk about
immigrants coming over the Border
because they don't want to talk about
guns going over the Border
you know it's always a deflection it's
always trying to switch it's always
trying to hey look over here look over
here let me say something that'll really
piss you off so you look over here and
don't pay attention that I just shipped
all the [ __ ] guns that are
responsible from the Via for the
violence to Mexico because Mexico is
really [ __ ] hard to buy a gun
you know it's always these deflections
with them always and that's what we're
seeing with farty March that's what
we're seeing with all of them
well and and you know the other thing
that they're trying to do with uh not
just uh Brazil but Hungary and all
around the world what they're really
trying to do is import export their
fascism because it's it's hard to
normalize it
um within a certain boundary or border
but if they can normalize this across
the world they can start getting people
here to believe well this is just
inevitable right right if they Import
and Export the Fascism and what I mean
by import export is they go they go
export their fascism wherever the [ __ ]
it is and they bring back some of their
fascism here we saw Victor Ormond
the [ __ ] Hungarian Hitler
come and speak at a CPAC event in Texas
and they had a seat back of it in
Hungary where Tucker Carlson was just
foaming at the mouth to get you know on
his knee pads for Ormond and this is
this is where we're at where they're
importing exporting their fascism to
normalize it and it's to normalize it in
the messaging and the narrative right
and that's what you know to come full
circle here at the end of the show
because I do have to I and you have to
get going on time today I've got to go
get my hairs cut and well I had to I had
to schedule an appointment and
um so for the audience out there the uh
the show will be edited and put up on
the directories Apple Spotify Google
just uh so you stay here with the Mohawk
down there again or what are you doing
absolutely no yeah I'm not getting my
hairs cut up here I'm I'm getting uh you
know I'm really strictly are you gonna
you're gonna let me script right you
know well here's the thing is I really
took this CBS Marge
um Marjorie Taylor green stuff seriously
and you know if I'm gonna if I'm gonna
be wearing a butt plug and using a dildo
I want it you know I want it to be fancy
and I'm just saying you know in the
holiday spirit of things I want it to
you know look nice I mean if you're
gonna you know if you're gonna be with
friends and family you might as well
absolutely absolutely well you don't
want to be sitting around with a
Marjorie Taylor Green in your anus and
not me no not at all you want to be
definitely
right you don't want a Madison cawthorne
butt Hawk no hell no no I gotta go I
gotta go so I gotta go get my hairs cut
today and tomorrow maybe you'll see if
it's um actually the hairs on my head
are somewhere else [ __ ] Dave man why
did you do that to me man I had had that
video out of my [ __ ] mind what was
with that [ __ ] phone or it's growing
out of that dude's ass man I have never
seen that much [ __ ] it looked like he
had [ __ ] Brown brillo pads shoved in
his ass crack that's Jesus thanks for
bringing that back up Gabe hey no
problem I do what I can I I I'm I'm
telling you
um you know I don't I don't think in the
spirit of Christmas you know right yeah
well Mary Merry Hairy Christmas
um but here here's here's here's the uh
the thing that I want to come back
around to to the messaging and the
narrative is that it's so important that
we continue we continue to pound the
drum we cannot let go of the narrative
we cannot let them take it we have to
keep going we have to keep leaning in
like Texas Paul was saying earlier and
the most important thing you can do is
support pro-democracy speech and the
best way to do that is to listen to it
and so Texas Paul tell us tell us about
your pro-democracy speech over on your
YouTube channel everyone knows you do
the Midas touch videos so go check those
out but go over and follow Texas ball
and his yeah
I took a little time off and and uh but
we're back at it every Sunday morning
we're doing the Sunday coffee with Texas
Paul hitting it every damn Sunday we
will talk about it everything that's on
during the week but we will tell you in
a way that that that only an independent
media broadcast can do
you know we're there's no corporate
sugar daddy there's nobody telling me
what to say how to say it I will just
look at what's going on and I will tell
you
unvarnished you know and a perfect
example is how I talk about Elon Musk is
he a [ __ ] idiot yes but if he dirts
[ __ ] in
all of those people working in the
gigafactory here in Texas are [ __ ] so
we have to figure out a way to unmind
[ __ ] Elon Musk unfortunately we don't
want to do it he's a [ __ ] we'd love
to cancel the [ __ ] guy but if we do
we [ __ ] the thousands of people that are
tied to her well so go follow Texas
follow the links down in the um in the
description on YouTube so go follow uh
Texas Falls channel for Sunday and also
do not forget to catch all the what was
that with Gabe Sanchez
um Gabe's been putting these things out
um they've been getting hundreds of
thousands of views on the Midas Dutch
channel so make sure to go over to the
minus stats Channel and check out
um
we need to put those on our playlist I
think I've been I've been slacking off
on you know so send me those and I'll
put them on a playlist all right um yeah
but what do you got what do you got oh
I've got a new version I got another one
coming we'll see we'll see how people
like it it's uh it's kind of like a
breakdown of how we found ourselves with
Margie Taylor green and Nick Fuentes and
Alex Stein and baked Alaska all of these
people how they ended up oh and Laura
Loomer how they're all stabbing each
other in the [ __ ] back right now and
how that all started and so I kind of
break it all down you know basically
like the breaking point was the dinner
with Trump and from there then they all
started [ __ ] stabbing each other in
the back and it's a big I mean the way
that I look at it and the way that I
describe it is more or less like
uh these are all a bunch of these mag
extremists are contestants on a reality
TV show a shitty reality TV show that is
the Republican Party
um because they're all betraying people
and talking [ __ ] about people and just
they're trying to one-up themselves so
they can be the highest one on the
[ __ ] [ __ ] pole you know well it
sounds like a sad sack of butt plugs
yeah so everyone go check out uh Texas
Paul's Channel go check out what was
that with Gabe Sanchez also do not
forget to subscribe here on the Tony
Michaels podcast at super important you
don't want to miss a thing and go follow
us at Tony Michaels POD at the Tony
Michaels and that I am Gabe Sanchez also
download every single episode Monday
through Friday on Apple Spotify Google
you can also download bonehead of the
week on Sunday while you're there
subscribing to your favorite directory
make sure to leave us a great review if
you're on Midas Touch Facebook page go
follow us on Facebook I think we're at
about a thousand now at the Tony
Michaels and while you're doing stuff on
your phone and you might as well
download it which app you might like it
over there too who knows who the [ __ ]
knows maybe we'll do some um special
butt plug streams I'm just kidding I'm
just kidding I swear we're not gonna
We're not gonna do that I'm just expert
I don't do the butt plug stuff you never
have and never worry never with the butt
stuff I don't know you know to each its
own I'm not gonna I'm not gonna King
Shame you know if you want if you want
the butt plug why not I'm I'm all for
the I mean at the end of the day
anything can be a butt plug that's right
and you know we're working uh speaking
of butt plugs we're working
we're working on getting we're working
on getting streaming on PornHub so
hopefully hopefully by the beginning of
the year I'll be a I'll be a legitimate
porn star and we can stream the Tony
Michaels podcast from from uh PornHub
but in the meantime go to visit
store.thetonymichaels.com there's no
butt plugs on there maybe we should get
some go visit
store.thetonymichaels.com show your
support you can also show show your
support by going to Tony Michaels dot
live you can leave a one-time tip or set
it up monthly you're the best audience
in the world Tuesdays are the best ever
with Texas Paul Gabe Sanchez I'm glad
you're back uh Texas Polk you're gonna
be back next week on Tuesday even though
it's a kind of a holiday week you're
going to bring the Christmas spirit next
week
oh yeah always man I love this shirt I
love doing this fantastic fantastic
everyone a great show today same time
same place tomorrow Surf's Up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ]
them
[Music]
Murphy's muleborn headass Beacon